[Musique]
le web
est cassé
j'en vois déjà allumer leur téléphone
pour vérifier
si je vous affirme que le web est cassé
c'est en regardant vers le passé
c'était quoi sa raison d'être
je m'appelle Thomas grange et je vais
vous raconter mon histoire de web dont
j'ai personnellement et
professionnellement suivi la croissance
j'ai grandi avec j'ai créé mes premiers
sites Internet lorsque j'étais ado dans
les années 2000
j'ai été un des premiers à monter dans
le train et à participer à ma mesure à
cette écosystème
alors pour les néophytes on va reprendre
de zéro
fin 1990 Tim Berners va inventer le
World Wide Web
cette invention à vocation a aider les
scientifiques à mieux collaborer
ensemble on peut en mettant en ligne
leur découverte
cette invention consiste en un langage
de présentation via le format HTML
et un navigateur qui va permettre de
résoudre une adresse ou url
d'ailleurs j'imagine que vous tapez
souvent des URL sur la barre de votre
navigateur qui commence régulièrement
par www et bien c'est une convention
pour dire word Wide Web
pour appuyer mon propos
on va prendre une bibliothèque comme
métaphore du web
alors à sa création notre bibliothèque
contient déjà quelques rayons de livres
principalement scientifiques
mais pour accéder à un livre bien précis
il faut connaître exactement la pièce et
l'étagère sur lequel il est localisé
on ne dispose d'aucune aide pour trouver
un livre dont on ne connaît pas la
localisation
au démarrage le web est une bibliothèque
sans bibliothécaire
alors ce qui va faire réellement l'essor
du web ce sont deux autres concepts
fondamentaux
le premier concept c'est le lien
hypertexte
vous savez ce sont les petits textes qui
sont soulignés en bleu sur les pages Web
un hypertexte va permettre de naviguer
d'un livret à l'autre d'une page à
l'autre
d'explorer une thématique donnée
ou d'approfondir en explorant des
thématiques connexes
l'exploration est infinie
et une première utilisation très
ingénieuse qui va être fait des liens
hypertextes va être par les premiers
internautes qui vont eux-mêmes donner
naissance à la bibliothèque qui nous
manquait tant
ils vont créer des annuaires web ils
vont pour cela lister quelques dizaines
de catégories
répertoriés tous les sites web les plus
pertinents pour chacune d'entre elles et
faire des liens hypertextes vers ceci
mais le deuxième concept qui va
réellement permettre l'essor du web ce
sont les moteurs de recherche
les moteurs de recherche fonctionnent
tous de la même manière ils vont se
balader en continu sur le web pour
tenter de découvrir de nouvelles pages
ou des pages dont le texte aurait changé
en cours de route
une fois qu'ils ont trouvé ces pages ils
vont alors lire tout le contenu les
indexer et en faire un classement
dans notre bibliothèque ils vont lire
livre après livre page après page
homoprêt
là où nos annuaires ne contenaient que
le titre du livre et son et sa quatrième
de couverture
on se retrouve alors avec une
bibliothèque avec des super pouvoirs qui
va non seulement nous recommander les
bons livres mais va nous amener
directement au bon chapitre et aux
bonnes pages
alors le web arrive avec plein de belles
promesses il va être facile de publier
stocké et va durer indéfiniment
ce nouveau aussi vers l'espace va tirer
de nombreux mouvements à commencer par
les scientifiques Berners était
ingénieur au CERN et a créé le web pour
pouvoir collaborer plus facilement avec
ses confrères
il va attirer aussi les libertariens et
les cyfer punks qui voit le web comme un
moyen d'échanger à l'abri des
gouvernements
les gouvernements évidemment qui voient
cela comme un moyen de simplifier leurs
administrations parfois
surveiller les citoyens souvent
et puis enfin les citoyens qui
deviennent réellement acteurs du web
avec l'arrivée du web 2.0 on publiant
tout type de contenu
texte musique photo vidéo
et en changeant également leur façon de
consommer avec l'essor du e-commerce et
décide de petites annonces
c'est à la fin des années 90 que le Web
devient réellement populaire auprès du
grand public
c'est en 99 que je découvre Internet
j'ai envie de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne donc je vais créer mon
premier site personnel dédié à la série
X-Files donc là vous me voyez si j'avais
eu 20 ans de plus si j'étais né 20 ans
plus tard j'aurais pu être influenceur
en mode et déco sur TikTok
donc j'ai donc 15 ans je bidouille des
pages HTML dans ma dans ma chambre que
je grave sur un CD et que j'amène chez
un ami en ville qui a internet car oui
j'habitais à la campagne et j'avais pas
encore de connexion
quelques décennies plus tard on est au
milieu des années 2010 on n'a jamais
autant publié en ligne
on rejoint les projets fous de la
science-fiction
dans le cycle d'Hyperion le perso qui
est un petit objet qui permet de se
connecter à une base de données qui nous
donne des informations sur la météo sur
l'environnement sur notre santé
Internet est dans la poche on y est on
est à l'apogée d'Internet
mais depuis quelques temps il se passe
un truc un peu bizarre
les moteurs de recherche semblent
gripper
ça commence par la plateformeisation
d'Internet
alors les premières années il fallait
avoir quelques notions techniques savoir
comment héberger son site web
coder sa première page web la mettre en
ligne
puis de nombreux services sont arrivés
qui ont permis de publier n'importe quel
type de contenu sans aucun prérequis
technique
aujourd'hui on publie directement sur
Linkedin ou Instagram parce que l'odeur
s'il est actif et que leurs algorithmes
vont nous amener des visiteurs beaucoup
plus facilement
le problème c'est que cette plateforme
peuvent décider de changer de politique
d'accès de jour au lendemain
si on revient dans notre bibliothèque on
peut imaginer c'est en plateforme comme
des maisons d'édition de livres
une maison d'édition pourrait décider de
déplacer ses livres de rayon
sans demander la vie préalable des
auteurs
aussi grave maison d'édition pourrait
décider de déplacer tous ces livres dans
une bibliothèque annexe
et alors on ne peut plus demander aucune
information à notre bibliothèque air au
sujet de ceci
puisqu'il n'a plus aucune information
dessus
second problème
c'est que les moteurs de recherche ne
sont plus être adaptés à la taille
actuelle du web
comme je vous lisais il y a quelques
minutes
les moteurs de recherche vont parcourir
le web en continu pour détecter de
nouveaux contenus
99,9% du temps d'exploration des robots
d'exploration est totalement inutile
pourquoi
tout simplement parce que les sites Web
ne sont pas mises à jour en continu
prenons l'exemple de Wikipédia la
majorité des pages on parle tout de même
de quelques dizaines de millions c'est
pareil va être mise à jour peut-être une
à deux fois par an maximum
alors que les robots d'exploration vont
passer une à plusieurs fois par semaine
sur chacune de ces pages
quand on pense que la moitié du trafic
d'un site internet est lié au robot
d'exploration on se rend compte que les
éditeurs de site web doivent allouer des
ressources considérables afin d'être
certain d'être indexées par ces moteurs
autre blocage
on se rend compte que nos livres sont de
plus en plus difficiles à lire
entre 90 et 2020
le web a beaucoup évolué
à ses débuts en consultait des pages Web
qui contenaient surtout du texte
quelques images aujourd'hui on peut lire
des vidéos on peut faire apparaître des
menus complexes au clic sur un bouton
on peut voir une page web indifféremment
sur un grand écran d'ordinateur ou un
petit téléphone mobile
là où nos premières pages web
ressemblaient plutôt à des documents
Word et ne pesez pas grand chose
aujourd'hui nous avons en face de nous
des mini programmes qui contiennent
autant de codes que celui de
l'ordinateur de bord qui a mené Apollo
11 vers la Lune
en conséquence aujourd'hui pour lire une
page web un moteur de recherche passe 10
à 100 fois plus de temps pour l'analyser
que nos anciennes pages
le bouquins s'empile dans la
bibliothèque et la bibliothécaire prend
plus de plus de plus en plus de retard à
les dépiler
alors que vont faire les moteurs de
recherche pour contrecarrer cela
et bien ils vont commencer par passer
plus de temps sur les sites les plus
populaires et en conséquence les sites
moins populaires auront des ressources
allouées plus limitées
ils vont aussi améliorer leurs
algorithmes en décidant de remonter les
sites qui vont avoir une meilleure
expérience sur un téléphone mobile en
conséquence un site qui pourrait
afficher des informations très
pertinentes pour être déclassé des
résultats de recherche s'il était trop
long à s'afficher sur un téléphone
on se retrouve avec une bibliothèque qui
a beau grandir d'année en année
avec des rayons cadenacées d'un côté et
des livres beaucoup plus compliqués à
l'air de l'autre
sommes-nous dans une impasse
alors j'ai envie de vous poser la
question
que veut-on faire du web
je souhaite un web plus soutenable et je
m'adresse ici à mes amis concepteurs et
développeurs de sites Web et le monde du
logiciel libre la plupart des hébergeurs
cloud a réussi à lisser sa consommation
d'énergie malgré l'explosion de la
demande et si nous développions des
services et des librairies avec la plus
petite empreinte possible
et pourquoi pas avec des indicateurs
environnementaux
je souhaite un web respectueux du savoir
l'auteur de recherche et éditeur de site
web doivent se mettre d'accord
pour améliorer la façon dont les sites
sont référencés en trouvant de nouveaux
protocoles et de nouveaux standards pour
une meilleure indexation et un meilleur
archivage du web
je souhaite un web réapproprier par les
citoyens
continuez à publier sur les plateformes
mais prenez le temps également de
publier vos contenus sur votre propre
site personnel que vous aurez appris à
vous-même héberger
mon métier
faire en sorte que tout auteur tout
livre du premier roman au chef-d'oeuvre
soit visible sur notre bibliothèque
commune
rassurez-vous des milliers de personnes
y travaillent déjà sur tous les
continents
j'espère vraiment
que la réouverture totale après les
travaux et pour très vite
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]